hello welcome back well authorities have
warned that the danger is not over yet
after numerous wildfires across the
country on the hottest day on record
well joining us now is dave walton the
deputy chief fire officer at west
yorkshire fire and rescue service um
what is the situation today
today is a very different day from
yesterday in terms of our incident
activity but um certainly here in
yorkshire the moment where i see it's
very muggy it's still about 23 24
degrees it hasn't rained yet in most
areas so the ground is still dry the
crops are still drying and everything is
still ripe for fire to spread if um that
the right conditions exist and then some
ignites from somewhere
and just talk us through what happened
in west yorkshire over the last couple
of days particularly yesterday how
difficult was the situation
i think was extremely difficult and i've
served for over 30 years in the fire
rescue service and yesterday was
certainly the most challenging day that
i've seen both firefighters on the
ground and our flight control staff
taking the 999 calls and the support
staff to just make this place work on a
day-to-day basis we knew it was going to
be hot of course we did we'd seen the
weather warnings then we made our
preparations for it but from about one
o'clock yesterday afternoon when the
calls really started coming in it just
became relentless i think i've used the
word brutal on a couple of occasions
firefighters were going from one
incident to the next to the next to the
next that they weren't getting the
chance to cool down and rest as we would
would only like them to do and certainly
that you know the 999 core handlers in
fire control as well um they were going
from one call to the next and we were
also taking calls for other fire rescue
services because every fire rescue
service around us was busy uh which also
led to the point that we couldn't help
each other as we would ordinarily do as
well you say of course it was a brutal
day that it was relentless um and that
obviously you did see the weather
warnings in place but do you think that
the
fire services and other emergency
services are equipped right now to be
able to deal with events like we've seen
i think up until yesterday morning i i'd
have said yes but we are still working
on the effects of climate change i think
yesterday was a game changer um we we're
certainly not immune to to the impacts
of climate change and certainly here in
west yorkshire you know we've been
planning because the modern fires that
we have up here we we run campaigns we
equip our staff we train our staff to
deal with what extended wildfires we
have floodings we're equipped and
trained to deal with them but yesterday
was really something very very different
it took
the moorland type of firefighting into a
suburban and an urban environment and i
have some shots that were shown from
london yesterday and the tragic
consequences down there fire getting
into an urban environment like it did
yesterday from an open field is
something that's really unique is the
source of only today really happens is
the likes of california and southern
europe
you say that yesterday was a game
changer what do you think does need to
get changed going forwards then
i think there's a number of things that
i think certainly was a fire rescue
service have to look at yesterday and we
have to learn from it i i was i think we
were very effective i think we can
always be better
i i i know people have different views
on this climate change is here to stay
days like yesterday will happen again
and again and again so we we we have to
design our urban our suburban
environments we have to modify our
behaviors and we have to accept that
working the way that we do living the
way that we do has consequences when we
have days like yesterday
and unfortunately the shots that i can
see on screen now that's the sort of
outcome that will happen if we don't
adapt to to climate change and its
effects of the sort of superheat that we
had yesterday
do you think you need more funding as
well
i i i think we'd always look for more
funding
everything more firefighters
more equipment always costs money it has
to come from somewhere um but but
equally just just to make a point as
well that yesterday was an extraordinary
day um there's almost
however many of our engines we could
have had yesterday we could have just
kept sending them to incidents so yes of
course there are funding pressures on
the fire rescue service
and firefighters as well um but let's
not lose sight of the fact that
yesterday was extraordinary and we need
to plan for the extraordinary going
forward
just looking at some of the pictures as
i know you are on the screen and it is
just extraordinary to see the
devastation that's happened
people's homes completely
devastated
what is the cleanup operation if you
like that is happening now to try and
help the people who've been affected
i i think certainly the the the images
that you've got on screen at the moment
um are clearly not based down in the
area but i don't expect the local
council local resilience forum would
step in the fire and rescue service and
other public sector agencies and indeed
voluntary sectors will be going in there
they'll be helping those people because
remember most those people maybe went to
work yesterday morning left the house
expecting to walk back yesterday
afternoon um but their that their their
clothes everything that they vital
medicines everything that they needed to
live their life is gone and turned to
ash so the level of support that will be
provided um from partners across a range
of um different different parts of
society will be absolutely vital to
those people just to get back on the
feet and then start to rebuild their
lives in their homes again
thank you so much for being on the
programme this morning this afternoon i
should say a really important voice
there dave alton
of the west yorkshire foreign rescue
service